ابرزه تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا قال سلاح الجو الاوكراني انه
اعترض 8 مسيرات وثلاثه صواريخ كروز خلال
غاره روسيه ليليه من جهته قال رئيس
الاداره العسكريه المدنيه في كييف ان
الجيش الروسيه هجم المدينه فجر اليوم
بطائرات مسيره من طراز شاهد
من جانبها افدت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
باسقاط ثمان طائرات مسيره من طراز شاهد
وثلاثه صواريخ موجهه من طراز كاليبر اطلقت
من البحر الاسود فجر اليوم وذكرت في بيان
ان قواتها تمكنت من صدها هجمات روسيه على
محاور بخموت ومارينكا حيث يركز الجيش
الروسي وهجماته على حد قولها وفي محور
ريزابيلوجيا وخرسون قالت الاركان
الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه استهدفت
بالقذائف المدفعيه عده مدن وبلدات في
المقاطعتين واضافت ان الجيش الروسي شن
عشرات الغارات والهجمات الصاروخيه على
مناطق مدنيه ومناطق لتجمعات الجيش
الاوكراني طوال الساعات الماضيه